hello everyone in this video we'll talk
about
hyper ige syndrome which is also known
as
job syndrome okay so this syndrome is
characterized
by skin abscess recurrent pneumonia
eczema elevated level of plasma
ige antibodies and ultimately
there is facial abnormalities and
fragile
bone structure so these are the clinical
features of hyper ige syndrome
the fact that is most important about
hyper ig
syndrome is that it is a inherited
immunodeficiency disorder so if it is a
immunodeficiency disorder and it is
inherited
there must be a defect or a mutation in
the gene
in this case of job syndrome the gene
is located in the 17th chromosomes
to be exact 17q 21.2
and this locus correspond to stat 3
gene a mutation in this stat 3
gene is the causal for job
syndrome so let us look at why stat 3 is
so
important in this immune aspect right
so stack 3 is involved in the
intracellular signaling cascade of il-6
dgf beta etc and all of these signaling
pathway are super
important for cytokine responses
for development of the t and b
lymphocytes
so that is why stack three signaling is
super important
now other than that stack three is very
important for th17
cell differentiation so stat3 is the
master regulator for that
now if stat 3 is mutated simply th17
differentiation would be abrogated
and th17 cells play crucial role
to modulate immune response against
fungal infections especially
candida albigans etc so th17 cells
production or differentiation into th17
sub-population
would be highly abrogated in job
syndrome patients
because there is a lack of stat3 gene
now if you want to
learn more about how our body fight
against fungal infection
you can click on the i button now let's
move on and try to understand the other
manifestations
so obviously il-17 and il-22
these two cytokines are very low
in job syndrome patients so
hyper ig syndrome patients are very
susceptible to candida albigans or
staphylococcus aureus infection
a normal person is normally immune to
these
pathogens and they can fight against
that
but for a job syndrome this could be
a life threatening problem okay so now
stat three is very important for
differentiation of t regulatory cells so
though t regulatory cells is regulated
by
other master transcriptional factors but
this state remediated signaling helps in
aspects of t regulatory cell
differentiation
so obviously il 10 signaling is
abrogated
in job syndrome patients if you want to
know more about t regulatory cell
you can click on the video in the i
button
let me tell you the plasma level of ige
is abnormally high in job syndrome
patient
generally ige is the least abundant
antibody present in the plasma
so chances of inflammation and allergic
responses are
very high in job syndrome patients
so just to summarize that what we have
learned so far
so first of all hyper ig syndrome or job
syndrome
is characterized by synapses recurrent
pneumonia
eczema and elevated level of ige
accompanied by facial abnormalities and
bone fragility
then the major cause of job syndrome or
hyper ige syndrome
is stat 3 gene mutation stat 3 is
involved in several aspects like il6 tgf
beta signaling
stat3 is involved in th17 subpopulation
of
t helper cell differentiation stat trees
is involved in t regulatory cell
population differentiation so all of
these
aspects would be abrogated in job
syndrome patients
lastly ig level is abnormally high in
job syndrome patient which leads to
enhanced chances of inflammation and
allergic responses
so that kind of summarize the major uh
aspects of
job syndrome or hyper ig syndrome and
lastly let me tell you that this
is a inherited autoimmune disorder
inherited
immunodeficiency disorder not autoimmune
sorry about that
so i hope that's all that kind of give
you an overall picture about
ige hyper ig syndrome so if you like my
video give it a quick thumbs up don't
forget to like share and subscribe
and my detailed course are available in
an academy
so if you want to access them you can
use my code mp10
to get a 10 uh discount for those who
you do who don't know
what is an academy unacademy is india's
biggest learning platform
and see you in the next video and please
let me know in the comment how you like
my videos thank you